hey 42 here Bethesda Softworks was
actually offered to make an official
open-world game of Thrones game in 2011
but turned it down in order to make
Skyrim welcome to RIF nearly 19-hundred
a group of US government scientist
attended a private dinner club in which
they only ate poisonous foods they
documented their illnesses in order to
convince Congress to pass food safety
laws they were called the poison squad a
man named Daniel balsam got so
infuriated with constant email spam that
he quit his job got a law degree and has
so far earned over 1 million dollars in
court judgments against the spammers
graffiti artist David Cho who painted
Facebook's first office in 2005 was paid
in shares which are now worth over 200
million dollars
13 of the 20 most polluted cities in the
world are in India during his Indian
campaign Alexander the Great encountered
a tribe that hadn't yet discovered fire
prostitution exists amongst some
penguins and chimpanzees they prostitute
themselves for things like stones or
food Prince Harry is partial owner of a
racehorse called
Usain Colt a ten year psychological
study found that men who kiss their
wives before leaving for work live on
average five years longer and earn up to
30% more than their peers who left
without a kiss odds are any memory you
believe you have before the age of four
isn't real they are most likely false
memories and have usually I ever been
told to you by someone else or you made
them up without knowing it before 2012
the largest buyer of kale in the US was
Pizza hot and they only used it as a
garnish around their salad bar during
sleep fluid in the body tends to pool in
low-lying areas which is why most of us
wake up with noticeable bugs under our
eyes
the average Bugatti customer has about
84 cars free jets and one yacht Estonian
ID cards have a chip with a
public/private key pair that's used to
sign documents and vote in elections via
the internet for their 2011 election 24
percent of the votes were cast alive
barely a year after the 1969 moon
landing the American public had
completely lost interest in space
exploration to such an extent that 90%
of people could not remember Neil
Armstrong's name octopuses are very
intelligent in 1875 1up deposit the
Brighton Aquarium would escape from its
tank when the guards weren't looking eat
the lawn fish in another tank then go
back to its own tank before the aquarium
opened thanks for the view subscribe for
more 42
you